pas même un mot monde s'était écroulé
c'était en 2018 samuel perd le contrôle
de sa vie ils voient des images des
souvenirs qui ne semble pas lui
appartenir dans le front j'ai cometti
diagnostiqués avec un syndrome de choc
post traumatique du padss
en compte
samuel a eu la force d'aller chercher de
l'aide auprès d'emphase un organisme
pour les hommes victimes d'abus sexuels
mais les hommes sont encore trop peu à
demander de l'aide prendre à des hommes
qui en détresse psychologique plus
grande mais qui ne vont pas voir les
ressources d'agde en partie parce qu'ils
ne les connaissent pas cet homme sur dix
affirment ne pas savoir ou demander de
l'aide et lorsqu'ils le font ils doivent
parfois être patient j'ai beaucoup
d'organismes qui peinent à offrir des
services rapides un contexte de
séparation conjugale quand on est dans
une situation crise parce qu'on se
sépare c'est pendant trois mois qu'on a
besoin d'un service c'est là donc c'est
sûr que l'argent où il est un obstacle
ama doivent être un obstacle la
connaissance des ressources après les
nombreux féminicide québec à dédier des
fonds spécifiquement aux organismes en
violence conjugale ce qui a fait fondre
les délais d'attentes dans certaines
régions maintenant ça n'est que deux
semaines d'attentes donc on est très
contents des ça mais si ce n'est pas
dans un contexte de violence il faut
encore patienter dans le réseau public
dix neuf mille personnes attendent
toujours des soins psychologiques un des
enjeux c'est que notre région est mal
formés pierre l'heureux a travaillé
pendant 42 ans dans le réseau de la
santé il croit que le système est mal
outillés pour accueillir les hommes dits
traditionnels que eux sont moins en
contact avec ce trailer réalité et leur
réalité en relation et parfois ils ont
de la difficulté même à mettre des mots
sur ce qui se passe ou ce qui arrive
exactement pour mieux répondre à leurs
besoins il faut former le personnel
majoritairement féminin que les
intervenantes et les intervenants soient
mieux préparés à recevoir des hommes
ayant de la difficulté à nommer leurs
besoins ayant de la difficulté à aborder
les enjeux émotionnels et relationnels
samuel lui apprend à vivre avec sa
sensibilité avec l'espoir que d'autres
puissent suivre et c'est pas vous
manquer une place au soleil
c'est ça change d'avis moi ça va changer
c'est marie josée paquet comme ou radio
canada montréal